a girl like me i'll be honest with you
they say the transgender girl that makes
the most money out here
is me the white girl with the
big dick i want to be frank with you
that's exactly what they say
the white girl with the big dick makes
the most money
because that's what they want
sometimes i feel like being homeless
well of course it doesn't give you curb
appeal
to pastor buyers but
it ruins all the good looks
everything beautiful you have about you
it ruins your feet it's hard to shave
and people walk by and they
make fun of you
sometimes
other races who are trying to get
social acceptance make fun of you
and don't realize that
you know
how hurtful that is and
it's getting more dangerous with all of
the homeless being put in shelter in
places
and the only people left out
are the people that are too crazy
to be able to be put in shelter in
places
so there's no one to talk to no one to
hang out with
and if you try to hang out with someone
they wind up crazy
and you end up having to make them or
going out to the host role sometimes you
feel like
the only people left to pick you up are
serial killers
there's no one out there prostituting
with you so
you feel like if you were to disappear
no one would even know
it's hard to make money
it sucks
and
i've been a little suicidal sometimes
um
freezing my nuts off
um every night because of san francisco
[Music]
um
i think i'm stuck um
i didn't get hit in the head after i saw
y'all last
this guy hit me in the back of the hill
with a 2x4
like it was like a stick a really long
stick
it was like broke off of a 2x4 and
and he hit me really hard and he hit me
so hard i almost
hit my face on the concrete because i
was sitting down in indian style
art let's be proper and say native
american style
but he hit me so hard in the back of the
head that i almost
hit my face concrete and
i went up to the hospital again
follow the police report tell him who it
was where he hangs out and they never
did anything
they never went and arrested him they
never
did a stay away order or anything
[Music]
i changed my services from the clinic i
was at
because i i feel like they weren't doing
anything for me and
i feel like i'm going to be the last
person out here on the streets
i'm lonely
i'm tired
i'm broke
i'm all this
and
i feel empty inside
but i'm okay
okay
i don't even have a phone parents just
told me
all my family just helped me
back in january
back in january
they waited till my mom died
she had a brain cancer
and then they were like
well mom gave me everything and we don't
have to give you nothing
and with that said
the rest of the family disowns you
and i was like
i didn't know what to think about it i
mean
it was [ __ ] up and i
and they even said things like well you
didn't love mom
anyway i was like how can you say that
i was like that's horrible i mean
of course i loved mom i mean
she loved coming down to new orleans to
see me and
we had such a great time
of course i just wanted him telling my
sister that
i hope that everything she left you
brings you all the joy in life and
everything you've ever wanted
including a new sister
and i just blocked him and
it gave him no avenue to find me and
i tried to find the peace in it i tried
to find
the positive and the negative
and
use it maybe as a drive to keep going
and i figured
since that was the case and they just
told me that
i would finish my transition
and make sure that they don't even as
much as recognize me when i get done
because if they don't want me then i
don't want them to be able to find me
and i figure i'd make my own family but
it's so hard to make a family out here
with anybody
because everyone's got ulterior motive
not that ulterior motive is bad at all
it's the type of ulterior motive people
have
you know nothing's free especially for a
girl
i mean if a girl wants something she's
always got to put out for it
you know
people are selfish
i mean nothing's free here you know and
all i
ever all i really want you know is
i figured
by now i would have met some guy
it's like oh
she's a kindness in the air
all right
oh yeah okay
see how sweet i am
it would have maybe scooped me up by now
and told me something like
i wish i would have met you sooner
but he has
sometimes i just want to jump in a hole
in a hide
i don't understand
i'll keep trying
you know there's no place for me to go
there's no place left
san francisco is it
i'm too old to keep traveling
i don't want to travel anymore
it took me six months to check out here
that was the last best time i can
remember
i was traveling out here from sanford
from new orleans
i jumped on a getting company tour with
my friend shiva
a car broke down in arizona i hopped a
fight
with a guy named possum some chick from
tennessee and a chihuahua
we got thrown off the train in the
desert walked a little ways to a truck
stop
after being sf agreed not to file
charges on us
for hop and afraid
and it was the last fun time i ever had
because i've been
i love it here don't get me wrong i love
san francisco
but a lot of times out here i'm
miserable
and unhappy
but i'm stuck here
and
i feel like
this place has disabled me
in what way i'm not really sure
it's caught it's got me caught up in
drugs
prostitution
sometimes i hate my life
hmm
hey look at how it all came to this
uh
and sometimes it takes me it takes
everything you need to
i still have the want and the drive and
the ambition
but i'm just so [ __ ] tired
i would sometimes just rather lay the
[ __ ] around
they carry on but if i lay around and
people stare at you
and they walk by and they laugh at you
and they snicker amongst themselves
about what's wrong with you
instead of like
helping walking through it with you
you know i think if i had somebody to
walk
through it with me don't have to do it
for me
just walk with me hang out with me
through it
it would
give me what i needed to accomplish
the things that i need to knowing that i
have somebody
there at my side to hang out with me
while i'm getting it done
and kind of like turning me on
being my little positive minion
you know i don't know
either way i don't see that i have any
other choice
you know what am i going to do
commit suicide i mean god
that would never happen
anybody ever said i committed suicide
they're lying
because i would never do that
i really wouldn't
believe me
i stay away from the right drugs like i
don't
shoot because i hate needles can't stand
them
they terrify me not even a nurse
can barely even stick me
i don't do fentanyl i don't do heroin i
don't smoke crack
you can't pay me to do it
regretfully i do crystal i smoke weed
and that's it it's like
there is nothing else but i do the drugs
i do because of my traumas
i won't go to a rehab
because they're almost just as
exhausting as it
being on the streets are for me
because i don't care for the principles
behind a narcotics anonymous
they tell you to demolish all of your
friendships
and things like that quit talking to
everyone
i just don't believe in that you know
i don't really have friends anyway
if you really think about it when i have
a cell phone
it's pointless because my phone never
rings
no one ever calls me i could have a
hundred phone numbers and no one will
ever call me
i'm always the one to call people
you know
friends are supposed to like call you
and
want to hang out with you and want to
invite you over and
they say what can i do for you you know
but it's always hey can i get this can i
get that
hey but no one ever
rings my phone that's how i know i don't
have friends
and that's lonely and no one does
deserve that
you know
you know i feel better that i cried
got it all out
but
i've got many more tears before it all
comes out
you know i don't ever get to talk to
anyone
you know i i don't ever get to cry to
anyone
it's always me and myself
you know i just i'm so fortunate that
being out here
and going through all this hasn't made
me crazy
so i can't imagine
going crazy
you know i the things that i see people
do out here
that are [ __ ] crazy
i mean please if you ever see me doing
any of those things please shoot me on
the site
please put me on my misery
because i mean i'm i get embarrassed
a lot out here and ashamed and
i don't like people seeing me like this
you know people go who gives a [ __ ] what
people think
well i do i do give a [ __ ] what people
think
i don't give a [ __ ] who you are where
you're from i give a [ __ ]
you know what i mean because i wasn't
raised that way you know me
and i do care i don't want people to see
me like this
i don't want people to see me on the
street sitting on the sidewalk
starving hungry begging i hate that [ __ ]
i hate it with a purple passion
you know i feel like being
transgender affects me getting jobs
i've tried to get a job in the last few
weeks
and i've got nothing
i uh
i've even been having people tell me
lately that i should
get in boy farm and i don't want to
i don't want to
you know i i'm not a boy
and they go well to move up in a better
position in life
sometimes you have to no i don't
i don't have to and i'm not going to
you know i'm either going to get
get it get the things i need moving to
the better position in life
like this i guess i'm not going to at
all
you know um
because i know me
i can get in boy for him sure
but as soon as i get a itch i'm going to
get right back in girl form and the
[ __ ] that i was sitting there
dressing up in boyfriend for
to please them they're gonna catch me a
girl form
at one point or another and when they do
cats out of the bag
and it'll all come crushing down anyway
so our minds will
stay in my comfortable form you know i'm
i'm a transgender woman and
if they don't like it they can suck my
[ __ ] dick
because that's what i tell them all you
know
excuse my language but that's that's
my favorite saying for those who don't
like me
um although i joke and tease about it
sometimes but
um i feel like i'm rambling
beautiful time thank you appreciate it
you did a great job
um and i appreciate y'all too y'all are
amazing
you know um i was glad i found you again
i'm so glad to be found it's good to be
seen to know i'm alive and to be around
it's nice to let you share your stuff
yeah for sure it's good to get out a few
tears
you know um it's not good to bottle that
stuff
in no you know that's got to be terrible
yeah and you'll help me out amazingly
considering between now and tomorrow
i don't know how to figure out my pin
number but
i might have to go back to the um
general assistance office which is all i
get i get like 588 a month
and 200 200 in food stamps
and i have to make that last an entire
month
and that's [ __ ] very difficult
i don't get social security i don't get
any other income
what about some of the guys you date
some of the guys that i date
oh i can tell you about them usually
they're married men
or they have ex-wives and kids
or sometimes they're drug dealers but
none of them
they all have one thing in common none
of them
want you to reveal their secrets
none of them want you to act like you
know them if you see them on the street
and some people are willing to go crazy
distances
to hide those secrets you know
they say so if you see me if if you see
me on the street do you know me
i've been asked that before by scary
drug dealers and everything and i go
nope don't know you never seen you
however if you're if they're alone they
might say you can say hi
and i've been in that situation too but
they get really [ __ ] nervous
like i've even i was in a shelter
in place at one time but somebody had
taken my
silicone breast because my breasts are
growing
and i'm on the pills so they take a long
time to grow
and i get very self-conscious so i wear
silicone fillers
somebody had taken them at the shelter
and place i was at
which wasn't funny and
[Music]
i tripped out about it
because that's like stealing my
prosthetics
that's part of my identity and i need
that
i feel like i need it
to survive
you know
to feel as real as possible
and i tripped out about it i did what
anybody would do
i didn't lash out at anyone i didn't
curse anyone out
i just had an anxiety attack and they
threw me out
and like i had accumulated
a good bit of clothes and shoes and
everything
my feet were back to normal i was
getting clean smooth shaves and
everything
and then it all went down the drain
i couldn't carry clothes so i had to get
rid of them
and then i realized i still had too much
and i had to get rid of them
and i'm down to now
a pair of shoes pair of boots super
stilettos
now they're one in which are good for my
feet as you can see
my my right foot
at times i feel like i can't feel my
toes
um i'm down to
a couple of mini dresses and a maze
skirt
maybe three mini dresses
none of which but one is a long sleeve
and it's lace
um no tint no sleeping bag no blanket
cause i'm too busy to carry that [ __ ]
around with me
you'll never catch me you can push in a
basket down the street [ __ ] [ __ ]
but at the same time at night time it's
so cold
i'm freezing to death
and i'm a cuddler so you know i like it
warm as it is
so the slightest cold makes me feel like
i'm
freezing and sometimes
it's near impossible to find a way to
cover up
and like i mean even ambulances
won't even pull over for you like i've
caught on my red lights and they just
spit off on me
when i tried to get a blanket you know
i've almost
went to the hospital and lied and said
that i was suicidal just so i can
get somewhere warm to sleep
and people are careless as if it's
always your fault
that you're out here and i got news for
you
i mean we all play a little part in
everything but
it's not always your fault that you're
out here
i came out here because a friend asked
me to come out here i was supposed to be
set up with a place to stay
and when i got out here around not being
what it was
and it winded up putting me out here on
the streets
and being out in san francisco on the
streets and trying to get on my feet
has been hands down the hardest place
i've ever tried to get on my feet before
because people here maybe it's
the locals or the friendly ones and the
foreigners are not
all i know is people are here are not as
friendly
as
people are not as friendly anywhere as
they used to be doors do not open
as freely as they used to
anytime they catch a person sleeping
somewhere
and they move you a week later they'll
come and thick and fence the whole area
off
everything's locked down everything's
fenced down
and you know i'm just i'm lucky to be
alive
that's that's to see it i'm lucky to be
alive
you know yeah but the guys are pretty
much sweet out here
um a girl like me
i'll be honest with you they say the
transgender girl that makes the most
money out here
is me the white girl with the
big dick i want to be frank with you
that's exactly what they say the white
girl with the big dick
makes the most money because that's what
they want
however i get a lot of guys that just
try to take advantage
they try to throw me spills like oh i'm
new at this
sure you are now i'm sure you got
coached by your friend
who told you if you come out to the host
role pretty much
you should know the prices you know you
should know that you don't come to a
host strong pick up a hoe
for free you know but my problem is
i just get a bunch of guys who want to
take advantage of me
that's all they ever want they want to
go
20 bucks 40 bucks no ma'am
no sir sorry no
i'm worth more than that i deserve
better
you know and those who treat me that way
should be ashamed of their self
you you know and it's an insult
you know
because i'm sorry but
having sex with all of these men it's
just
too much work for that amount of money
they expect too much for too
little and afterwards
don't get me wrong and no girl could
probably sit there and say
otherwise neither we've all been
desperate one time or another
you know and from that experience
afterwards when all they give you is
like 20 bucks or something makes you
feel
like [ __ ] makes you feel horrible
and it's unfair
and i don't appreciate it
so usually after the first guy tries to
run game on me
he usually kills the whole wanting to
hang out the whole stroll usually i'll
just wander off
and girls tell me all the time they're
like you just be patient
you just tell them no and don't drive
around the block a few times they'll
come back and they'll pay you the price
but i don't even want to i don't even
want to hoe i don't even want to
definitely don't want to hoe after the
first one tries to run game
because i tell them no and then by that
point my feet are killing me
because i'm too antsy you're not going
to catch me standing in one spot
you know i'm i i walk slowly
you know but yeah that's about how it is
you know but eventually
yeah it's true you'll meet a guy
eventually and
he'll grow a liking to you however i'm a
white girl
all of them grow attached to me a couple
of them
i had one get possessive stabbed me in
the knee with a syringe
um
i don't luckily i don't have hiv or
or hep c i i did just get std cured but
i'm lucky i haven't caught hiv
you know i need because i would just die
the way i'm terrified of needles i can't
promise you i could do it
and i would probably die
and that's the honest truth they would
have to have a living nurse live in with
me
and make sure that i take my shots and
go in for my levels and stuff
because i can't promise you being that
i'd have to go in for blood levels that
often
that i could do it i mean they have to
chase me as it is just to get me to go
into the clinic and get a shot
so i guess like one thing i could change
about my life is
i could start being more careful
because i'm not the care most careful
girl i know
so um does that wrap up our session
it does all right it's definitely great
talking to you love y'all
thank you very much okay and y'all on
camera too
you're so cute oh thank you
thank you very much for sure
do some of the girls hate on you i know
they have to
but you're a handsome guy i don't know
i don't know i'm all business but i'm
doing this
and you should be you know